where are we supposed to get a couple of
new puppets like the Bobo puppet those
puppets could be made easily they take
time Howard they just came in yesterday
afternoon there's they're sitting right
by my desk we haven't even open them yet
oh no rush
well if we wanted to wait to show you
and show Fred and we don't want to just
drop it on you in the middle of a show
what do we have a Bobo puppet now have a
Bobo and a tan mom you feel like trying
out the Bobo puppet Fred I could try it
but we'd have to get him on right now is
the puppet gonna be as boring as Bobo oh
you got the Bobo puppet yeah I know yeah
oh my god oh my god this hand I have my
boys jewelry where the guy didn't really
studied Bobo it's even Bobo's teeth he
got those right yeah does the hair
remove it does oh this is hysterical
does he have lesions on his head yes oh
that guy is good Bobo has lesions on his
head from his hair glow yeah Bobo so uh
you used to be a driving and struggle
you know hands tenant oh the new law is
free and knowing because of the airbags
some people say eight and four I find
that very dangerous
we even got Shirley the Tan mom puppet
look at Shirley all hopped up as a puppy
boy Tan mom how are you
hello Bao Bao how are you my hair my god
time to tan
good I was at a tanning I thought that
was a blow-dry I was gonna have you
touch me up hey Bobo you attracted to
tan mom I find her very sexy you
couldn't last two seconds on this ride
I love the puppet titties look at those
that puppet nipples on ha is very cold
in here I think so sexy tear mom yeah I
think she's very very pretty and I want
to grab the Weejuns on her chest yeah
take my puppet do you have a metal plate
in your head that's right I do look you
can hit the tanning gun on it nothing
gets through nothing
was it a car accident you have to be
very careful how's your singing career
going oh my god you want to hear some
yeah yeah what are you gonna sing it's
Patricia wow that was great thank you
yeah what a good singing voice the top
of my head look who's excited now Bobo's
excited because now he's here to kill me
oh my god the bubble puppets
Wow I'm very very excited about this
that we excited it was a great show
until you called yeah it was actually
rolling pretty good yeah we were having
fun with Bobo let's burn the puppet now
I like that Bobo called in and is
ruining the Bobo Park like as soon as he
calls [ __ ] why do we have a Bobo pump
it again hang up on this idiot
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you